OnOn conclut la semaine en bonne
cocompagnie. Madeleine Blais
Moririn, Sébastien Beauvais chef
dede bureau respectivement à
QuQuébec et Ottawa.
cecette confirmation du débat à
teterme après le mandat de Madae
BlBlais.
UnUn dossier difficile pour le
gogouvernement Legault.
- - Comme si l'idée de laisser
cocouler le fait que Madame McCn
n'n'allait plus candidat.
- - C'est ce qui est arrivé.
- - Quand on joue à cache-cache
avavec un enfant, des fois il mt
lala main dans le visage comme e
lele voyais plus mais on le voit
enencore. Au gouvernement,
prprobablement au cabinet du
prpremier ministre qui a pensé
avavoir la brillante idée de die
: : si on laisse couler le fait
quque Madame Blais et Mccann ne
sosont pas candidates, vous voyz
quque les personnes qui sont
coconcernées ne sont pas
cacandidates.
- - Mise été pris de court?
- - C'est le moment sacré, c'est
trtrès difficile de confirmer en
gégénéral qu'un député va s'en
alaller parce que tout le monde
auautour de ses députés le prote
popour dire à moment donné, il a
popouvoir parler  aux gens de
cicirconscription, sa population
popour dire j'ai fait mon bout t
c'c'est assez. Ici tout le monde
esest surpris de leurs réactions
dede parti. Madame McCann dit
ququ'elle aurait souhaitée
l'l'annoncer aussitôt de son coé
enen premier. Madame Blais dit-
elelle aussi après un engagement
popolitique. Elle retweete un
ararticle de la presse qui dit e
lala dureté surpris de s'en allr
cece matin.
- - Quelle histoire ! On a
bebeaucoup de choses à dire.
DaDans quelle mesure cette semae
sisi, tout ce qui a été écrit
popourrait avoir un effet sur
l'l'élection partielle de Marie
ViVictorin est-ce qu'on pourrait
vovoir ça comme un baromètre dea
gegestion du gouvernement Legaut
dede la pandémie?
- - On verra bien ça. Peut-êtren
rérésultat serré entre les
cacandidats en lice. La de l'ail
fofois y avait 25 % de taux de
paparticipation.
EsEst-ce que les gens de Marie
ViVictorin vont vouloir
sasanctionner le gouvernement pr
cece qui s'est passé cette semae
esest-ce qu'ils voudront avoir n
dédéputé qui est avec le
gogouvernement?
CÇa reste à voir. C'est sûr que
lala semaine a été mauvaise. Es-
cece que les électeurs de Marie
ViVictorin emportée une attentin
paparticulière à suivre les
cocourriels, les textos, les
atattaques des uns et des autre.
UnUne chose est sûre, les gens
veveulent savoir ce qui s'est
papassé dans la première vague e
lala pandémie. Est-ce que ça vae
rérépéter dans le veau de Marie
ViVictorin?
OnOn verra.
- - À Marie Victorin il y a un
tetest. Un test pour la CAQ. Sa
gegestion de la pandémie. Les
gegents qui sont années de touts
leles mesures de la pandémie.
LaLa CAQ a eu déjà une érosion e
soson vote même s'il reste
prprédominant au Québec. Il y a
ququand même une érosion dans ls
sosondages. Il y avait un test
popour la CAQ avant cette semai.
IlIl y avait un test pour le Pai
ququébécois. Est-ce qu'il est
enencore capable de conserver un
sisiège comme celui de Marie
ViVictorin. C'est difficile de
rérésumer l'élection partielle à
unun seul enjeu, celui du CHSLD
HeHerron, qui est quand même
drdramatique.
- - Dans cette circonscription n
vovoit la classe en 43 %, le Pai
ququébécois avec Monsieur Nantel
ququi s'accroche aussi à cette
cicirconscription .
- - Si tous les ans vôtre, ce ne
seserait pas le cas. Si le tauxe
paparticipation est faible, quee
esest la meilleure machine
élélectorale : est-ce que c'est
cecelle de pianoter qu'à des
raracines profondes au sein de a
CACAQ?
LeLes envois des ministres, des
coconseils politiques toute la n
dede semaine pour essayer de
coconvaincre les gens de voter
CACAQ. Ça va être intéressant.
- - Pas son budget fédéral. Un
mumusée qui montre une alliance
enentre libéraux et néodémocrat.
EtEt Madeleine vous diriez que
c'c'est les passions ce que ça?
- - Oui. Il y a le plan dentaire
ququi est une influence
nénéodémocrate. C'est le gain
prprincipal néodémocrate dans un
mamariage Parti libéral est pari
nénéodémocrate. Ça se retrouve
dadans le budget. C'est aussi un
tetest pour ce mariage la, à
sasavoir si ça tiendrait bon,
jujuste au début de cette lune e
mimiel où voyagent de noces?
VrVraisemblablement, oui. C'està
cece qui sera peut-être difficie
popour l'alliance néodémocrate-
PaParti libéral. Parce que le
dédétail qui sera fait par la
susuite n'a pas été véritablemet
coconclu.
LaLa première année a été
vévéritablement détaillée dans
l'l'entente. Par la suite il
fafaudra négocier.
IlIl y a eu cette teinte orange
avavec le plan dentaire sinon
c'c'est un budget libéral, et
c'c'est un budget libéral et on
hahabituait à un Parti libéral
dédépensé depuis le début du rèe
TrTrudeau. Avec ce budget
FrFreeland, elle ne dépend pas E
mamalheur qu'elle a réussi à
dédégager au cours des derniers
momois encore à cause de
l'l'inflation. En raison aussi e
l'l'économie qui tourne rendemet
enen ce moment, ce qui génère ds
rerevenus entre autre grâce aux
rerevenus d'emploi par exemple.
- - Les provinces auraient voulu
avavoir un peu plus de détails,n
pepeu de saut à l'intérieur de s
fafameux transferts en santé.
JuJustin Trudeau a rejeté les
crcritiques selon laquelle il a
fafait la sourde oreille aux
prprovinces?
- - Oui, on a hâte de voir commt
çaça va se dérouler la
nénégociation. Parce que dans le
bubudget d'hier, il y avait non
seseulement pas de nouveau
trtransfert, ou les transférer
sosouhaitées par les provinces,
mamais il y a aussi les petits
popois envoyés aux provinces.
QuQuand on parle des pays de
l'l'OCDE, on dépense plus pour a
sasanté mais il y a de moins bos
rérésultats en trop pour ce qui
esest de la santé. Façon de dire
quque vous n'en faites pas assez
avavec l'agent conversent, alors
sisi vous voulez en avoir
dadavantage il faudra que vous
amamélioriez vos performances.
C'C'est une tractation difficil,
susurtout que l'agent n'est pasà
etet que les conditions... les
crcritiques sont formulées.
JeJe ne pense pas que c'est bien
rereçu du côté, chez Sébastien
BoBovet, dans le gouvernement
LeLegault notamment.
- - La réaction du gouvernementa
étété de dire que c'est une
occasion manquée. Ça dit tout.
SoSonia Lebel disait que
l'l'occasion été ratée d'augmenr
leles dépenses de la santé et qe
lala demande de toutes les
prprovinces et augmenter les
dédépenses en santé. On se prépe
àà des négociations difficiles.
DaDans le petit lexique de la
popolitique au Québec, une bonne
chchicane avec le gouverneur
féfédéral, c'est payant
élélectoralement. Les élections
s's'en viennent au Québec. C'est
unun bémol. Ça fait payant
d'd'affronter le gouvernement
féfédéral message de donner de
memeilleurs soins aux populatios
apaprès être sorti d'une pandéme
ouou près de 15 000 Québécois st
momorts, est-ce que les gens vot
didire : prendre l'argent,
fifinançons réseau de la santé.
S'S'il y a des conditions
rarattachées à sa, sa donne de
memeilleurs soins, pourquoi pas.
JeJe ne suis pas sûr que c'est
auaussi payant cette fois-ci
d'd'affronter le fédéral en dist
ququ'on va refuser votre agencel
y y a des conditions.
- - L'argent n'est pas encore sr
lala table. Ce n'est pas comme i
FrFrançois Legault disait :
j'j'attends avant de le prendre
cecet argent. Je ne veux pas de
coconditions.
IlIl le dit bien qu'il ne veut s
dede conditions mais il demanda
dedes sommes que le gouvernement
féfédéral n'est pas prêt à donnr
popour le moment.
- - En termes de négociation,
cocomment ça pourrait être fait?
UnUne province à la fois?
C'C'est un peu ça la question?
- - C'est une stratégie que le
gogouvernement Trudeau a adopté
enentre autres avec les premiers
FrFrançais négocier. C'est aussi
cece qui a été fait avec les avs
dede garde. Jusque-là ça été
papayant pour le gouvernement
féfédéral. Je ne vois pas pourqi
ilils sont sur une recette
gagagnante.
- - Pour la semaine prochaine vs
y y préparer toujours. Qu'est-ce
quque vous surveillez?
- - Procède à relâche
paparlementaire. Ce ne sera pas
trtranquille pour Justin Trudea,
etet ses ministres,
- - il y a le service après-vene
àà faire?
- - Ça commençait. Après avoir
vovoté le budget on veut le faie
aiaimer. Promouvoir le plan
lologement dans le budget. C'est
lala mesure phare aujourd'hui.
IlIl est en Ontario en train de
fafaire ça, promouvoir le plan
lologement.
- - Sébastien, de votre côté?
- - Lundi soir, on verra si on a
ététat, c'était serré, mais il a
dedes choses à analyser dans cee
élélection partielle dans Marie
ViVictorin.